[Musique]
ça c'est ma camionnette que je travaille
moi et mon petit fils on travaille en
deux mois on partage en deux je suis
allé à la rencontre de familles roms de
la région parisienne les roms aussi
appelé gitans aux tsiganes c'est une
communauté d'environ 7 millions de
personnes principalement basés en europe
de l'est
en france il y en aurait quatre cent
mille diego sud ouest
je lui ai offert montrer comment on
travaille comme en ramasse la ferraille
les voitures comme ça les voitures
brûlées moi je pourrais ramasser poupée
ou quatre mâts il prend pas de nos cases
parce qu'il n'ya pas des documents ils
pensent qu'ils sont des voitures volées
ou je sais pas quoi
je touche pas je touche pas à ce qu'ils
gagnent 1 500 euros
allô allô et vous pouvez revendre et ça
combien bon une tonne une tong 80 euros
travailler trois semaines idrac 54 ans
j'étais en france depuis sept ans et en
plus la pauvreté il doit affronter de
nombreux préjugés
[Musique]
l agent et pons n'importe quoi de qui on
est malade on est des voleurs qu'on ait
de jeu papa comme les jouets vont voir
c'est bien ici sur le terrain pour voir
comment travaillent ils vont poser
on sait d'autre chose de mon art
partout justement il ya pas mal de gens
qui viennent
pourquoi les jeunes sont des contes des
les manouches et français voyageurs puis
les joueuses ont tort parce qu'ils
comprennent pas la vie des gitans on
vole pas des gens font ça me plaisait
pas pour être dans une caravane au
soudan sur un terrain que j'ai pas de
nos j'ai pas de courant je parle rien du
tout son président la maison qu'est-ce
que je peux faire
je n'ai pas de chance et alors je suis
sur le terrain comme ça
miodrag vit dans un bidonville à 30 km
au nord de paris ici dans la plaine de
pierrelaye depuis quinze ans près de 200
personnes vivent ici dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
il n'y a ni eau courante ni électricité
jeanine membre d'une association vient
régulièrement en aide à ces familles
roms
bonjour à tout à l'heure
l'habitat pierre lille a donc tout prix
dit si on se connaît ce lieu depuis
qu'il existe en fait donc depuis 17 ans
on peut venir vous nous avez promis le
café voilà alors nous voilà
allez c'est un lieu excentré de tous il
est loin de toutes les villes loin des
écoles loin du travail vraiment les plus
d'une heure pour aller jusqu'à la gare
de pierres les akyé c'est difficile les
conditions matérielles sont dignes du
siècle passé vite
vous avez pas vu à pierrelaye il cherche
un chauffeur pour la navette pour les
colas ça c'est le problème parce que moi
je suis pas don comment l'état est
européenne noser à oui oui oui je suis
allé et m'ont dit vous êtes monsieur
nasser vous pourrez pas très bien avec
les autres documents
c'est aux romands oui comment je peux
faire supporter aux moi ma
professionnalité ses vétérinaires
je suis venu en france parce que je
n'avais pas de travail et de mon pays
parce que je suis
handicapé c'est juste que le montrer ma
carte que je suis un vétérinaire
je peux pas travailler avec clément
celles âgées l'opération cela elle est
paralysée
il met cinq mâts il m'a demandé mes
papiers pour remplir pour un handicap et
noir pour une demande de reconnaissance
d'un handicap et après peut-être
quelques fois il ya eu un petit peu
d'argent
non je peux pas toucher l'argent parce
que je pèse mes mots mais pas ceux de la
carte de séjour ce ateliers toutes les
démarches la mois après ce qui inquiète
le plus jeanine c'est la santé des
enfants
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'ici tous
les sols sont complètement contaminés au
plomb et un taux trop élevé dans le sang
des enfants peut provoquer des retards
de croissance mais surtout de graves
problèmes mentaux à l'âge adulte
cette maladie c'est le saturnisme on est
venu avec l'agencé régionale de santé
en janvier le 20 janvier au niveau du
temps il ya eu des prélèvements ici et
puis deux trois places ailleurs et dont
les résultats sont que vraiment il ya
chez polluer quoi il ya du plomb bien
sûrement d'autres choses parce qu'ici en
fait c'était une zone d'épandage de
l'eau des eaux usées de paris dont il y
avait tout un système d'égout de
canalisations et ils ouvraient des
vannes et l'eau se répandait dans toute
la plaine de pierrelaye et du coup tous
les sols sont pollués
s'il ya beaucoup d'enfants il ya
vraiment beaucoup
et comme l'école est très noir dont
quatre étaient juste là risation le
collège il ya trois enfants qui vont au
collège les autres mais voilà ils sont
là toute la journée quoi c'est ici donc
on a découvert qu'ils avaient du plomb
dans la terre et vous êtes parmi les
premiers à avoir fait des analyses c'est
l'idée que chez les premiers et tous les
enfants qui sont ici ils ont trop de
plomb dans le sang
et ça c'est quelque chose de dangereux
il faut déménager si on n'a pas de
logement on a déjà fait beaucoup de
demandes de logement et on va continuer
que vraiment tout soit mis en oeuvre
pour que vous puissiez être relogés
lisez il est très plaisant jai alai
séquelles à la poussière si je te montre
en main généraux guerre qu'est ce qui
est sûr le alain bouton non il faut il
faut pas que ça dure un oui
tu sais qu'il ya du plomb là c'est un
peu dangereux quoi pour des enfants oui
ça l'est déjà il a dit qu'il aimait ça 6
va rester un droit pour tous tant pis c
est parce que tu sais la tamise au ceva
grandi les niveaux grâce à cette agence
et peut faire des premiers avec la tête
six adultes ils y sont un peu ils ont
pas toutes leurs têtes s'est sentie
c'est grave donc c'est pour ça qu'on
fait le maximum à ce moment ça va bien
monsieur donc c'est monsieur et puis les
trois enfants
cette famille elle vit de la mendicité
comme beaucoup de familles roms mais
c'est pas non plus le cas de tout le
monde dans le bidonville
on a aussi beaucoup qui viennent ici
pour des jobs saisonniers qui peuvent
être payés jusqu'à 10 fois plus qu'en
europe de l'est
c'est l'avocate autres à offrir quelques
comics toute l'agriculture de la paix
est là pour relater la vie et la
coulisse et de toutes pistes et que
c'était matière politique et inutile non
conforme ni aux pommes ne connais aucun
nom mm d'eau des carabines des mots que
notre machine system of a down under my
son my son my son verbe internautes
actifs en thaïlande au myanmar il est
question partir de cobalt
chez façon les liens de sa famille ils
ont travaillé toute l'année en france et
s'apprête maintenant à rentrer deux
semaines en roumanie pour les vacances
dubaï compte et comptera pétrole a même
ramené va surfer foodie oil et friedrich
nietzsche en poignée d'autres magazines
people et s'attaque à ce tableau sombre
et la première place à mont cassin ça
dépend de ma ford gt gt gt c'est un bris
la ghost rider
ah ah ah ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]